listen the game of business is about
having small markers over your
competition and one of the ways you can
have it is on Sunday nights because very
few people prepare Sunday night for the
entire week today I'm gonna give you 10
things I do to prepare for my week on
Sunday night so listen before I get into
it I want to thank you everybody for
helping value team across eight hundred
thousand subscribers it feels like
yesterday we were at five thousand subs
now we're only two hundred thousand subs
away from crossing a million subscribers
on this channel and by the way today's
episode these ten things I want to cover
with you that I do on Sunday night this
was inspired by Antone my friend from
Croatia who sent me a Jersey brought it
to Dallas Texas with my last name on the
back on tone knock each this episode is
dedicated to you number one so first
thing I do is I grab a blank sheet of
paper and I categorize it in five
different categories business finance
health spiritual family right and every
time I fill this out by the time I'm
done with my strategy session those
to-do lists end up on my phone so it's a
reminder throughout the week on what I
need to do next
number two so once I have my to-do list
sheet of paper right next to me on the
table the following thing I do is I go
to my calendar and I go back to 90 days
this is why I go back 90 days couple
reasons one I'm going back to find any
leaks of people I need to followup on
when I do that I write the name here I
need to followup with John family I need
to followup with Bob business I need to
followup with such-and-such personal
trainer health I make my notes here the
next thing I do is accountability I look
at my daily monitoring activity let me
explain to what I mean by daily
monitoring activity every single day I
have a certain set of activity I need to
be doing so I score my week was this a
seven was this a nine was this a perfect
week a ten whatever your numbers are for
your business I don't know what it is
you gotta have certain criterias to make
it a ten when you have a ten you green
it out this week was a ten this week was
a nine but I gauge my week after week
after week so once I have this set up
then I look at my following week that's
coming up for my schedule so one is 90
days the other one is the next week
coming up this prepares me mentally and
what's coming up then
week number three so look no matter who
it is whatever kind of a business you're
on everybody typically has a handful of
people they can contact on Sunday night
or Saturday this is like your main core
team right so I asked them I said listen
this week we have this project coming
out what's going on with this and this
week we got this gonna battle are you
prepared with this how are we fully
prepared for this one thing that's
coming up to Marcus we have to be yes we
are I'm gonna communicate typically on
Sunday night with five to seven of my
direct people that I'm working with so
they are also prepared for the week
because if I wake on Monday we're
already behind the eight ball number
four so the next thing I do is I make a
list of people that need to hear from me
this week meaning vendors partners
executives sales clients who needs to
hear from me and what kind of message is
it is it an encouraging messages and an
accountability is that a report is it an
update is that a direction is that a
challenge we need to improve in
such-and-such area what is it I may get
that as a list of people I need to
followup with and I add that to my to-do
list number five so now that I've done
that my to-do list is gonna tell me any
big meetings that have coming up a board
meeting right maybe I'm having a
investor meeting I'm having a meeting
with certain carriers insurance
companies and what do I have to prepare
for this meeting right so stuff that I
need to prepare data quote if it's a
sales training whatever it is I need to
prepare for that and others if it's
investors what other deck do I need to
have a presentation of PowerPoint if
it's not a lot great if it is a lot I'll
make sure the people that are helping me
with this start putting it together as
well number six so one of the things I
like to do is I like to send gifts cards
you know any kind of certain things
flowers edible arrangement I will make a
list who is supposed to be getting
something from me this week that list is
also made on my to-do list by the way
this is family business finance every
one of them who needs to hear from me as
far as a gift goes and that goes out the
following week number seven so depending
if you're married you have kids you're
single family mom dad brother system
boyfriend girlfriend whatever maybe I
ask what do we have going on this week
do we have a birthday going out do we
have wedding what do you need me at I
need to know what is needed for me this
week specially if you have kids it's
very critical for you to know hey we
have a family thing going on with the
teacher here on such and such date great
I'm ready for it and we move on number
eight so next thing is I'm reading I'm
reading a book I'm reading articles I'm
reading news I'm
reading industry stuff that's taking
place I'm going up and studying right I
gotta get my mind mentally prepared for
the crazy week that's about to come up
and I feed myself for about an hour
reading on Sunday night number nine so
right after that what I like to do study
numbers I mean I love studying numbers
because it tells a story right so yes I
track my activity on 90 days and what I
got coming up this week
but what I do next is study numbers
actual numbers if you're doing real
estate how many homes did you sell last
month the month prior to that I sit
there and I look at how many people that
we sell a policy to how many people was
a week before how about the week prior
to that what are we doing Q 1 to Q 2
what's Q 3 looking like last year's Q 4
I'm looking at all of those numbers
together to prepare me and know exactly
where my business is at today because I
don't want to be caught with a surprise
when I go in knowing wait a minute this
one that is low
this one's high I want to know all of it
before I start my week number 10 so this
last one we sound weird too but I
prepare my clothes for the following day
because I don't like to wake up in the
morning lucky my closet saying what am I
gonna work if I had a my ride we're a
white shirt every single day with blue
jeans and flip-flops right but some days
I'm meeting with investors so I put my
suits up to tie all this others on my
workout clothes night before so in the
morning I don't need to do any thinking
about clothes so listen the whole
purpose of doing this is for two reasons
one for you to be prepared for your week
so you're not really stressed out going
to sleep at night and two to actually
have a strategy going into your week by
the way
think about what a small percentage of
people actually spend a couple hours on
Sunday night preparing for their week
10% you're beating 90 percent of your
competition if you do this so for some
of you that are watching us impact I
wish I had this on PDF Mario our hero
has prepared a one-page PDF you got a
click on a link below download it take
it out and look at and say here's what
I'm gonna start doing on a weekly basis
and by the way for some of you that are
saying man this I found so many leaks in
my business if I'm not doing this
there's a video this video itself or
consulting could be a hundred thousand
dollars for me to spend time breaking
down the leaks people having their
businesses but this video is also in
value teaming the title of this video is
how to find leaks in your business if
you saw this video go to that video as
well because that's going to help you
find other leaks in your business that
you currently have so with that being
said
the way if you haven't yet subscribed to
this channel click on that alert button
forget about just to subscribe click on
alert button so you're one of the first
to get any episode that comes out on
value Tim and take everybody bye-bye